hey everybody is Jessie and today I
wasn't exactly sure what I'd be doing so
that's why that's the title for this one
is purposely vague right now
I'm working on the the resources page
and on the the new user interface for
that page and I was actually just adding
an atom package to to help with my code
formatting so we talked about this
yesterday I think Sebastian brought it
up and I have it on my laptop but I'm
gonna install it now so today it'll just
be like maybe just some random things
I'm getting to the end of the list here
so let me show you
so I showed you yesterday how much was
left that I needed to get done basically
most of it needs to get done be done
this week I have maybe a day or two next
week I think that I can work on this but
it needs to be done but I was able to
complete a few of them but then go
through this and I moved I moved to
bunch them up over here into this
category so that if time allows I will
do it so we'll see if I can get through
this then maybe I'll do some of these
but after I read through them again I
realized you know some of them weren't
they weren't as necessary as I thought
they were when I first when I first put
them in these rows so for at least for
now we're gonna start out working on the
UI which is already taking me longer
than I thought it would take in
particular right now I'm having this
this problem so I have this drop-down
and this uses a little bit of JavaScript
some jQuery from the materialized
framework so it needs to be initialized
to be able to do this but what's
happening is it's getting initialized
before the data is populating so I need
to figure I need to figure out a way to
stop that from happening
so I'm double checking right now that I
actually have yeah so let me let me pull
this over on to my others from my other
screen just to show you kind of in the
code what's going on make it a bit
bigger it's too big okay so you see we
have here's our all our data is coming
in with our categories for resources so
the people in charge of putting in the
data which actually I think it's just
one person right now is in charge of
putting in data in in WordPress have
evidently been putting in some
categories which is awesome it gives us
more data to work with so they're here
they're getting put in here but you can
see when this gets initialized what the
user sees is you know this list but all
that's in this list is the first option
because that's hard-coded in there so I
need to initialize it afterwards so I'm
thinking maybe there's some lifecycle
method in react that could help out with
this so right now I've made a component
for this select thing because I'll
probably reuse this on other pages
probably the blog page possibly the
events page so I thought it'd be better
just to pull this out into a component
so within the component I put in
component amount to initialize that
select input so I'm thinking maybe I'll
have have to find a different life cycle
method and if you're not familiar with
react that simply means like component
did mount is a life cycle method is it's
something that happens during a certain
part of the life cycle like the life of
a component so when a component is going
to mount when it actually did mount when
it's going to to update so there are a
bunch of them until maybe we'll have to
go to the react Docs and check out some
other ones and try out and see if we can
if we can get this working so other than
that I had some pull requests so let me
show you the new stuff had some good
stuff in here let me find it I thought I
had it ready but maybe I
maybe I didn't yeah I must have
navigated away from the page so I'll
just bring this over so this will show
one of the pull requests that I haven't
brought in yet let me go
hey everyone okay I just saw on the live
staff and they said that he has a pull
request so yeah it's it's we're gonna
we're gonna check it out right now so
this is Vinay's request which is pretty
awesome so I have I pulled down the
branch to my local machine and tested it
out and it's working great
I just haven't merged it in yet so
basically what would Vinay's done and
since since he's in the live chat he
could explain it more in the live chat
as well and if I mess something up
explaining it he can correct me but
basically he switched to using pre-act
which is a smaller version of react
right so he switched to that and it
makes that everything smaller I'll just
I'll show you and you can check it out
as well this is on the repo but let me
let me show you some of the things so
you can see the bundle has gone from 271
kilobytes down to 143 so it's pretty a
significant drop you know
percentage-wise and the size so that's
really cool also he added this this
analyze command here that will basically
bring up a page like this and it shows
you all the dependencies everything is
going on in your build so it's really
really cool
and I was actually able to see I wonder
if you can see it on here I don't know I
thought when I ran it anyway there were
some things that I'm not using in the
newer versions that of the resource page
like masonry that were in here that I
could see that now will be gone so it's
just kind of cool that I get a visual of
everything that's going into the project
and be able to see the size I was kind
of surprised how you know some pages are
bigger than others and trying to figure
out why so really cool so you can if
anybody wants to to check it out and try
this or anything the the pool request is
is here you know you can pull that down
if you want I will be merging this in
probably later on either later on today
or tomorrow morning I'll be pulling that
in I did want to ask this so I've never
used pre X so I want to ask if if
anybody has used pre X I'd like to know
what your thoughts are on it did you
have any issues with it so so far our
testing it out just locally click like
everything works there's no errors or
anything happening so then they did a
great job but since I've never used it
before I just wondered you know should I
be looking out for something I read
through the docs a bit just to
familiarize myself with it a little more
but I'm I'd really like to hear your
opinion on it you know so anybody that's
used it please let me know if there's if
there's no objections that I'm
definitely gonna you know merge that in
and use it so let me show you
I had another request to and yesterday I
talked about that Andrew had submitted a
pull request based on
on the search and then he also had some
comments on how to make it even better
so he actually went I opened up an issue
and then he went and made a pull request
that that did everything that he had
recommended so really awesome so it
looks like I mean it seems like he put
in some time to this you know based on
what always was changed and everything
so he pulled in the debounce from lodash
and used that so you can check out the
code is all on the resources page now so
you'll kind of see it as we're going
through because we're going to be in the
resources page and you can you know
might go through it briefly just to see
what was done but if you want to check
it out in more depth this is actually on
it's merged into the master branch now
so you can see it in action I haven't
pushed anything from master up to the
live site yet so you can see it on
github but you won't be able to actually
use it unless I mean unless you wanted
to download the whole repository and run
it locally but I will be pushing things
up yeah either later today or tomorrow
so anyway Andrew thank you so much this
was awesome and I really liked reading
through the code both from Andrew and
Vinay and just learning from what you
both did so both of you thank you this
was really awesome and I guess I'll show
also the contributors page I actually
like have this up on the screen just
every time I start just so that you know
like you're gonna get up there I guess
if I started getting a ton of
contributors they wouldn't fit on the
screen but for now it's nice if I get
any more it's gonna be a little tight
maybe two more could fit but anyway I
just want to make sure that you get the
recognition you deserve for helping out
so that's why I show this so
let's I'm just going to jump right back
in where I where I was before I started
this dream and just continue on oh I got
a few questions let me let me go over a
couple of questions first in the live
chat I mean it's just maybe two of them
so Josh asked how to set up the night
theme on github okay so I had a lot of
questions about this yesterday so let me
show you basically you need two things
you need tampermonkey which is a plugin
for Chrome so in the in the chrome I
don't know if it's called a chrome store
or I don't know what they call it but
where you normally get chrome plugins
from get tampermonkey then once you have
tampermonkey you want to get the github
dark and i'll copy let's see let me get
the URL and I'll just put it in the chat
alright it looks like the update URL on
the download URL is the same thing so
this URL is where you should be able to
download this code so you'll want to run
this in tampermonkey and then enable it
for github which I think it's all setup
for I don't think you really have to
setup anything else except just put this
code into tampermonkey so that's
basically it you may have to if you
don't know how to use tampermonkey you
may have to mess around with it for a
bit but it's really not hard I think
it's it's pretty straightforward it's
basically just a place where you can put
JavaScript and have it run when you go
to a certain site automatically so you
put it in the JavaScript and you say
which site to run it on and it runs
really straightforward and then once you
have it on there you you have this new
Settings panel this github dark Settings
panel and you could do you could change
everything you could customize it you
could even go into the code and make
your own theme if you wanted to I just
use the default theme that came with it
I haven't even looked at any of the
other themes yet but I guess it would be
cool to match match it up to the theme
that I use in my code editors so the
highlighting would be the same but for
now I'm happy with it how it is ok the
other question I had was let's see
I lost it no okay Adam so Adam asks did
you graduate from fus which is
Franciscan University of student Moodle
so that's that's the university that I
work for so no I actually didn't
graduate from fus so I went to actually
the cheapest college in the state of
West Virginia and if you're not familiar
with West Virginia it's one of the
poorest states in the United States of
America so obviously the United States
of America
in terms of you know average income it's
higher than a lot of other places so
when I say poorest states it's relative
to the United States which basically
means to be considered poor in the
United States you know by government
standards you can still have a house and
a car and cable television and Internet
and so it's not really like you're
you're destitute but basically the
school I went to was so cheap I think I
only ended up paying like four hundred
dollars or something to go there after
you took into account like scholarships
and I did get student loan money and
things but I ended up investing my
student loan money since I didn't need
to use it I guess I needed to buy books
oh I take that I did have to pay for my
book so that that cost a little bit more
but I ended up making seven hundred
dollars off of investing my student loan
money and then whenever I was done with
school I just paid it back immediately
before I had to start paying interest so
so everybody is always talking about how
much school cost but I think I actually
made money off of college so I was I was
a business major and I was wanted to be
a stockbroker so that was very in line
with what I wanted to do but anyway the
Franciscan University is quite a bit
more expensive than the university I
went to which was West Liberty State
College it's West Liberty University now
they changed the name but when I went
there was just State State College but
anyway Franciscan University is is not
like one of the most expensive colleges
out there it's it's pretty affordable
for what it is but it is a private a
small private college so small private
colleges usually are more expensive so
anyways sorry for all that none of that
really had anything to do with code but
and it was a long answer to a simple
question but I just always like to tell
the story about me making money off of
off of college of my college loans back
then the interest rates were a lot
higher so you could you could make more
money off of really safe investments and
something like money market funds and
stuff at high high interest rates let's
see-oh ahead here we go right off the
bat we have a question about the text
the text out of the code editor so
Sebastian says Windows notepad for the
win I actually used no pen to start
learning how to how to code so that was
the first thing I learned out of code on
back in I think like 2003 maybe 2002
somewhere around there so something like
somewhere around there I think I learned
on notepad which was was super fun so
it's somewhat sarcastic it was fun to
learn how to do it but doing it on
notepad was not fun anyway I'll keep it
short in terms of talking about the
editors and you all can talk about as
much as you on the live chat I like Adam
because I've been using at them and I
have a lot of packages set up and Adam a
lot of plugins but I also use Visual
Studio code occasionally and I will say
it seems faster than Adam so one day
maybe I'll switch if I ever take the
time to set up you know similar packages
in Visual Studio code but those are the
only ones I really have very much
experience with I did use notepad plus
plus when I was developing on
a Windows computer before I switch I
switched from notepad plus plus to Adam
like years ago so no plaid plus plus was
okay at the time I wouldn't have said I
was a serious developer at that point so
it it worked but I thought it would
never go back to it
okay so let me let me get back and do
some coding and then I'll check back in
in the in the live chat and so if you've
asked a question stick around for a
couple minutes and I'll check back in
but I'd like to try to do keep a nice
balance between coding and and the chat
if I can all right so the problem the
problem right now is how do we get this
to initialize after the data's come in
and the potential solution is let's look
up life cycle methods for react
components
I guess I'll go the official Doc's are
probably a good place to go so let me
make this bigger and I could probably
make this a little bit bigger on the
screen - okay so we're already using
component did mount and obviously that's
not working for us right now so any
lifecycle methods that happen before
that are not going to be of any use to
us so maybe maybe component did update
the other thing is is this says when
it's when it's being re-rendered it's
possible that this will always fire
since we're making an API call to get
the data for that so that might work
it's worth a try so which I component
did update
and let's check out see what's going on
oh hey it worked they're awesome I want
to do do two things I want to try a full
refresh and then I want to try to you
know do click on these links to do that
client-side routing and make sure it
still works so let's go to events and
then we'll come back all right that
works awesome so here's a good tip I've
had for some reason I've had a few
questions about using jQuery with react
so I had a discussion on Twitter about
it recently and in a live chat I've had
some comments about it we did a stream
about it before but this is some good
advice so if you need a component to
have some data that you're waiting on
first and then initialize it component
did update seems like it's the way to go
all right so that's all that and that
was a much faster fix I'm so glad that's
something that I've fixed more quickly
than I thought usually it's the other
way I think something's gonna be easy
and then end up spending an hour on it
but the next thing is I don't really
want to keep this with the discolor
that's not it's not the color so I got
to decide what color I want to make this
do I want to keep it white or not and
then what color text I know this
background is black but I really I don't
want to make this black I'm not even
sure that I want to keep this black for
now anyway but I'm not gonna mess with
it right now at the very least I'll
change these colors to this red color
that we're using for lengths here and I
think I'll just leave it at that for now
and if I get any ideas on something else
I think that should be okay I wonder how
many categories they're gonna add in
here I was just saying this this may end
up becoming quite large which I mean I
guess that's if that's what they want to
do that's fine might be difficult to
scroll through everything at least it's
in alphabetical order so that should
help get through it
so I'm going to grab the the hex color
for this and then apply it here I'm
gonna check out in dev tools quickly
what that color what that color is where
I need to put it
where is this
I think that it's not try this again
there we go that's what I wanted
okay so here's what we want the span
inside the Li so looks like the
drop-down content will change the color
here so let me just grab this let me see
my component
yeah I'm gonna I was I'm glad this
happened because I I've discovered
something else
that doesn't work when I'm using jQuery
okay so on some of my components you can
see that I've used like this CSS you
know right here either in a style tag or
you know directly in line so when I'm
using these things from the materialized
framework that use jQuery to manipulate
the Dom which really I just don't have
time to rewrite them in a better way for
react but let me see basically what's
gonna happen is I can't put it in line
because that I mean you can see here
that list all those outlines don't even
exist those get added in when it's
initialized I can't put it in that style
JSX tag because what that ends up doing
see if we can find something okay so
what ends up happening is like here it's
given this data
- JSX number and that's what's used see
if I can find a style for this okay so
that's what's used for these Styles so
if you could see over here the stuff in
the style JSX tag and the component ends
up being converted into something like
this where it uses these IDs well
what'll happen is if your component has
features that are going to be
dynamically added after the fact then
it's not going to get one of these these
IDs so whatever in the background does
all this is not even going to see those
elements so you can't use that so you
basically have to go back to plain old
style sheets so I was trying my best to
get everything I could
out of this stylesheet and I found I was
I was trying to get take as much as I
couldn't put it in the components and it
wasn't working and that's how I
eventually found out hey it doesn't work
if you're adding things dynamically so
I'm still gonna have to keep some things
in the stylesheet I won't be able to put
it all in the style JSX tags so anyway
just wanted to fill you all in on that
in case you were working with something
similar so what I need to do then I
think I copied what I had to copy but I
need to put it in this style dot CSS and
I'm just gonna throw it down the bottom
so my CSS file is a mess I was trying to
edit things earlier and it's like really
I guess I didn't copy what I thought I
copied but it's actually getting really
hard to edit things because the CSS is
just all over the place so I really need
to take some time and and work on that
if I do get time which I don't know if
I'll have time any time soon but that's
also if you're if you're kind of just
starting out and you want to get a you
know you want to build up your github
profile that might be something somewhat
simple to start out with just to go
through and mess around and see how much
of the Styles here you could pull out
you could either take out completely
because I've already duplicated it in
the components or pull it out and put it
in the components make sure it still
works that's just kind of tedious work
that's not difficult but it just takes
time to do in the tests so I know
sometimes it can be hard starting out
contributing to projects so it's good if
there's some kind of like easier tasks
and as always I don't I don't expect
anyone to contribute to this this
project you know I I'm happy of y'all
just watching and everything but if you
want to I really do appreciate that let
me see I need to grab the color I
thought I had it out here somewhere I
guess would be done yep I have it done
here I will say this if I was really
setting this project up in a better way
right off the bat I would have like CSS
that gets imported and I could probably
have I could probably be running SAS
have variables for my colors potentially
I could even set up like real JavaScript
variables since I'm using you know
JavaScript within or I'm using CSS
within the JavaScript so there's a lot
of different ways I could do this that
are better if you haven't been watching
you know from the beginning this was a
conversion from a static site so a lot
of this is just left over and in reality
some of the things that are still in
this CSS file aren't even being used at
all because they were even pulled over
from a previous site that was entirely
different at a different color scheme
and but it was a good jump start to this
project so there are things that are in
here that have never been used on this
project that just never got taken out so
I'm not saying that's a good way to do
things or just explaining this the
current state of the project so I need
to do a hard refresh because I don't I
don't get to refresh when I edit a CSS
file the auto refresh okay that looks a
lot nicer than the yellow it's
definitely easier to read and it fits
better with the color scheme alright
that works now I actually I don't think
I have this working yet
yeah it doesn't work so maybe we'll do
that so I did get get this working which
this wasn't difficult it was just a
matter of adapting the code that I think
Fabian had done a pull request and I
just needed to adapt it so that I wasn't
using masonry and I was instead using
these I can see this I'm not getting the
the border on this top one so I'm not
really worried about it now because I
think bill who's frequently in Live Chat
sent me some code to do a nice effect
with a horizontal rule instead of a
border so I'll probably replace that
anyway so I'm not going to worry about
that right now but let me commit this
before we go on to the next thing and
I'll do it on on this screen so you all
can see especially if you're if you're
new to get into the command line they'll
give you a little bit of extra a little
extra info about it I'll explain it as I
go along so we're on a separate branch
we're not on the master branch we're
doing all this new stuff on the new
resource UI branch so if you want to
follow along in the in the repo on
github that's the branch we're on so
we're gonna do a get status just to make
sure what's change okay occasionally you
do a get status and you see something
that's changed and you don't know why so
I always like to do it unless I'm
absolutely sure what's changed and it's
only a minor thing I always want to
check so resources component has changed
the style sheet has changed and then
I've added this material select
component so that's good there's what
that's expected so we can do get add and
put a dot to add everything and you can
see now everything's ready
for me to add a commit message to and
then I can take it commit and then if I
put the M flag I can put my message
right here if I leave out that flag and
I just hit Enter when I hit get commit
it will pull up whatever your preferred
editor is which by default might be Nano
but for me I think I set mine to be atom
so then you would have to put in your
message otherwise like that if you have
a really long message that's probably
the better way to go but this is faster
if you have a short message so in this
case mine would be
mmm I don't think I've really done
anything else that's that pretty much
sums up what I've done I think we have
an error oops
so an it select it's not defined so what
I need to do is just put in an exception
so that it doesn't throw this error
anymore so that's cool I'm glad it
through that error because I don't think
I ever explained live why I needed to
make these exceptions okay so let me
show you so up here I've needed to put
this in so what I'm using some type of
like an it function that I have here in
my app is file I've done this it throws
an error if I try to use it without
putting this and so in it and it select
so now we'll ignore the fact that this
is not defined so there are better ways
to do this as well - this was kind of a
workaround to get all my jQuery stuff to
work now we'll try again it should work
this time well that's alright so that
works
and I'm gonna push that right up to get
it up immediately so y'all can see it if
you want to and I'm gonna check in the
live chat now since there's quite a bit
going on in there and I don't want to
get too far behind
so next step I'm saying this out loud so
I don't forget as well next step is
going to be actually hooking this up so
when he click one of these it actually
works and it filters okay so the Nate
says check out pre-act compact which I
used it adds react compatibility layer
for pre-act
the only issue I face is with react
transition group for which we can alias
to our C CSS transition group okay so I
did read a little bit about the pre-act
contest so I saw that that's what you
had had used but in the I guess it was
in the package.json file I saw that so
that's if you're just joining and you
didn't hear at the beginning vinay had
submitted a pull request that would
shift everything over to pre-act which
is a more lightweight kind of version of
react and he's also added something so
that it's compatible with what we've
already done called pre at compat so
vinay saying there's one issue so I'm
not exactly sure with the with the issue
is I mean Vinay it sounds like you know
you have a handle on it
just let me know is this an issue that
should I wait on pushing this you know
out to the live site to production or if
should it be okay because I I have no
experience at all with pre act so I'm
relying relying on you on Vinay and all
of you to fill me in on any potential
pitfalls
okay let's see
hey zan is here hey Ben didn't notice I
saw it yesterday I was and I saw you'd
said goodbye and then I didn't even get
to that part so sorry I did say goodbye
on the video but I think you'd already
gone but so a belated goodbye and hello
nah okay all right now I see most of
what was in the lab chat was still
talking about code editors as usual
okay I see now as Anna just said
yesterday when I said I was sorry I
meant sorry had a rough tough weekend
you know what I am when I was driving
home from work yesterday I it hit me
that that's what you were talking about
and I felt like an idiot because I had I
just totally forgot sometimes it's it's
hard it's hard to keep since I can't
keep up with the live chat and code at
the same time and I have to take breaks
it frequently happens that I forget what
I had said you know just a few minutes
before and then you you were you all
were responding to what I had said but I
I just don't I don't get it because I
don't remember so I don't really know
the way around that because there's
there's just usually a lot of activity
in the live chat so I really can't I
don't think I could do both I couldn't
respond to every message as it came in
in real time and still code so but I'll
do my best to try to remember that but
anyway thank you for that Anna I
appreciate that
I had we had we had a loss in a family
over the weekend so yeah I was just
pretty down about that and I think I
didn't realize it yesterday but this
morning I woke up I think I'm starting
to get sick like a cold or something my
throat's a bit swollen and it hurts so
that might have been adding to it but
it's just feeling you know a little
weird and down like out I don't know if
they were happy to you but I was
literally like I was sitting here I was
working yesterday morning you know
writing some code and like I didn't know
where it was just like I felt like I was
gonna start crying
and it just passed over me it was like
five seconds and then I was I was okay
but I was like man Leawood is going on I
think it was just like the emotion of
everything that happened like I just was
really busy and it hadn't hit me until
like that point and then it just all hit
me at once and then I was okay but we'll
see I'm actually gonna go see I go to a
counselor
once a month and just for some like
minor depression and stuff but I see you
later today so in a couple hours so
maybe I'll bring it up and make sure I'm
not going crazy or anything but anyway
enough enough about my mental health
sorry for the for the tangent
okay we had a question so Viper I behave
I'm not sure if or announce that I
really sorry I I know I probably messed
that up it's vai be hav says unemployed
I stay at home all day how can I keep
learning to code and build projects how
can I be productive I would say if if
the trouble is like just staying
motivated to be productive try to find
projects that you you really care about
and then maybe that'll be extra
motivation if it's something you can get
excited about then I think it'll be a
lot easier for you to keep going also
this is somewhat I guess unrelated to
coding but I found it's helped me out as
well if I can get in a little bit of
exercise you know every day I find that
I just have more energy and motivation
I'm much more likely to actually do
something and sometimes I'll get a bit
of exercise and a solution to some
coding problem will come to me while I'm
I'm exercising and so I don't I think
there's something about the effect of
exercise on the brain that helps you
work through problems like that so if
that's a possibility for you as well
that would that could could help but I
know it's tough I went through a period
of being unemployed and then I've gone
through when I was freelancing I've gone
through periods of not really having you
know clients or not a lot of clients you
know and those are tough periods too to
try to go through but you try to like
set a schedule for yourself and try to
be consistent you know that can help to
set some goals but hopefully but you
know keep keep me informed keep us
informed maybe it would be good if you
know occasionally if you can join us for
the live chat and just let us know what
you're working on everything then that
might help as well that you know you
might get excited about you know filling
us in on what you're doing
and if I see you if I remember and I see
you in a live chat you know it in the
future I'll ask you how things are going
so you have a unique name I haven't seen
anybody else of that name so hopefully
I'll remember and I could ask you anyway
hopefully that advice helps I'm sure you
know people in the live chat have some
great advice as well Court Court says in
Russia computers have only two gigabytes
hard disk that's crazy it's that serious
as anybody else from Russia can you
verify that because that sounds really
really crazy I mean if you were like on
a Chromebook in that cloud storage it
that would be fine but yeah really crazy
Jordan asks what packages do you use I
don't know I use I have a lot of
different packages so I don't know I
can't really go through them now maybe
I'll try to make a video on all the
packages I'm using I guess I could while
I'm going through some of the questions
in the live chat I'll put up on the
screen the packages I have I need to
configure this but I won't do it on on
the screen because that'd be kind of
boring but if you want the style JSX tag
to be highlighted properly there's a
little bit of code you have to put in
here so I'll need to find out where that
code is and copy and paste that I think
it's in the documentation for next j/s
so if you wanted to use this to get
better you know syntax highlighting and
things and auto indentation just now you
have to put that little bit of code in
so let me show you here's here's just
some of the packages I have I know this
is a little bit small but if I make it
bigger you won't be able to see as many
so I'll leave this up here for now and
I'll scroll down a bit in a few minutes
that way you can see what I'm using the
court court says no coding I want write
code now
is they are you meaning that I should
quit talking and write code or what or
you want to write kiss either way if you
want to write code go ahead but I'll get
to the code in just another minute
there's not a lot left here in the in
the live chat okay Sebastian said that
yellow is unreadable at least in the
stream is Hannah agrees yeah for sure
that yellow I've had issues with that I
actually found a slightly different
shade of that yellow that works a lot
better so I've used it in some other
sites if you if you like if you convert
the color from a hex color into like the
H hlsa color or something I might have
those in the wrong order the you can
darken it right so you can keep
basically the same color but darken it a
bit and then it makes it much more
readable but it doesn't really change
the color that much so it appears to be
the same color but it's just a lot more
readable so I've switched to that color
on my newer projects but I think the one
that was still there was leftover and
kind of like the base theme that I
always use for university websites oh as
Anna said I hate it when CSS is all over
the place yes yes they'd say just it
just happened you know at some point you
just started getting so much CSS and if
you don't like me if I just I didn't I
just didn't stay on top of things and
then I got out of control
so I'll have to keep that in mind the
next time I'm doing a project so that
I'm more disciplined about my
organization right off the bat okay
Sebastian says you can import your CSS
and the components you can make a CSS
file per component so yeah Sebastian
that's that's a better way to do it and
that's what I'll if I have time I'll
probably go that route the reason as I
said that it was in one big component or
one big file was because that that's how
it was
in the site that I I came over from so
you just never got around to actually
splitting it up okay Jeremy like said a
couple things and then retracted and
said never mind I got it so so glad you
got it here on Evo or Ivo Ivo says hey
James I've been following the live
stream along for a little while and I
understood that you have built a
reactive website with WordPress as the
backend and then Sebastian corrected as
Jesse yes it's cool I know what you
meant actually when you said that it
reminded me of the characters from
Pokemon just like the Team Rocket
members once named Jesse and other ones
James it's like my kids are really into
Pokemon right now so that's immediately
I thought of that so anyway to continue
on Iowa says I'm really curious as to
how this worked out for you and what the
lessons you learned about this project
my previous internship used to Drupal
backend and its HTML engine so Zanna did
explain he just uses the WordPress API
to pull data out from another website
that that is true yeah then he thought
apologized for I getting the name wrong
it don't worry about it
it's not a big deal so anyway he said
the solution with the Drupal engine
usually involve writing custom
JavaScript code which always overwrote
each other and made a huge mess of the
HTML as well as the application state
yeah that sounds like a mess yeah so
anyway legs Anna said since I'm not it
I'm just taking the data that's entered
into WordPress and I'm not using their
templating system at all so that kind of
eliminates a lot of the issues that I
would
if I was trying to work in to the actual
like the templates I'm not sure what the
terminology is in Drupal I haven't
worked with Drupal that much so I'm like
the terminology might be a bit different
from Drupal WordPress but you know
normally these templates are made in PHP
and then they get rendered server-side
with PHP and HTML if I was trying to use
Java scripts or real react in particular
with that I probably would have run into
more issues but since I'm doing it this
way and I'm basically just dealing with
data coming in the form of JSON it makes
it a lot easier so I actually am
interested though and how you would
potentially do the similar thing with
Drupal because there are some sites
connected with this site that I'm
building that are built on Drupal so
there's a learning management system
that is that this site is going to
direct people to and then they'll go and
they'll sign up and it's like I think a
yearly fee or something and they'll be
able to take all these courses that
system is built on Drupal and then
there's another site that's a magazine
that's associated with with this website
and that site is built on Drupal as well
so potentially if I could expose Drupal
data through some sort of API I could
pull it into this site as well that
would be nice because the people
entering in data wouldn't have to
duplicate data so I'm interested in in
that I don't have direct access to any
of those Drupal sites like it to the
backend so I couldn't implement anything
but there's an outside company that that
is building those so potentially you
know they would have to set up the API
and then I could use it but I assume
that Drupal could do something similar
to what the WordPress API does it'd be
even better if it would use graph QL
instead of a regular REST API but that
would be ideal if you if you don't
haven't heard of graph QL check it out
it's
GRA pH and then the letter Q and the
letter L really really cool what's it's
like I I suspect that it's gradually
gonna take over a lot of things that use
a REST API now we'll switch to graph QL
but for right now there wasn't an easy
way to do that with WordPress so that's
why I just stuck with a normal API
oh no Sebastian said apparently what I
said about CSS doesn't work on next Jas
oh I'll have to keep that in mind so
splitting up things into like separate
CSS files for components doesn't work so
off to check that out more there's got
to be some better way to do it also
Sebastian mentioned by the way you're
missing the border bottom in the first
item from the list yeah I did I saw that
let me let me switch back to here
actually let me let me put up while I'm
going through this I'm gonna put up the
code all here I had the code on the
screen what am I thinking I want to put
this up here so you can see some of the
stuff that Andrew did to change
basically make the the search function a
little bit better so it won't make so
many API calls it works better with like
the mobile virtual keyboard so you just
kind of check this out now of course
this also on the github page Sebastian
says sorry to hear about that yeah I
appreciate that
thanks for saying as anna says we're
humans not robots crying his natural
yeah that's true that's sure it was just
odd to have it happen like right in the
middle of just just working just going
more often and nature helps a lot
actually that's a good idea I haven't
spent that much time outside for a while
I did go to the beach a couple weeks ago
so I just went some time at the beach
but that might not be a bad idea I
actually have like my my house has a
little over an acre of land around it
and part of it is just like yeah it's
just a bunch of trees and stuff so but I
rarely get out and actually enjoy it I'm
always you know coding or something so
maybe I ought to just go out and walk
around take the kids they'd probably
like that
okay Zanna had some advice for the vibe
have which like I said I'm sure I'm
probably mispronouncing your name if you
want to try to explain how to pronounce
your name I I will definitely try to
pronounce it correctly from now on but
anyway the advice is write emails for
startups out there I'm sure you could
find an internship the best way to learn
is coding real stuff small tasks so
anyway that's that's great advice I
wouldn't never even thought about that
of just emailing different companies for
internships and stuff but that's a
really good idea Jeremy says in the same
boat but the live chat helps me a I'm
really glad that this the live chat is
helping helping you all I do
I think the latch that is one of the
best parts about about this that's why I
take so much time to try to read out
everything that I can in the live chat
for the people who are watching later on
because if the if the show was just me
talking it wouldn't I mean it would not
be nearly as good and helpful for people
I think you all make it so much better
okay yeah ratha asks can we watch this
afterwards and Umberto's says yes the
video is posted in about five minutes
thanks for answering that I'm just
reading it out loud for in case you know
anybody else I imagine there might be
some people watching this they can't
look at the live chat for whatever
reason maybe they're they're just
listening to it and doing other things
so I just wanted to read that out for
those people Zanna recommends let's see
following sites like remote okay or
internships and found a startup cool so
Zanna actually was able to find a
start-up for an internship so that's
that's awesome so that's definitely
really good advice so if you're in that
same position you know just trying to
get some experience and you know just
doing doing side projects and things you
know definitely try to get a hold of
companies you like and get an internship
I vote says I checked out graph QL
before and it's really interesting would
recommend it as well you pronounce my
name is Eva okay awesome Dutch
pronunciation is weird okay cool alright
so I'll try to remember that so Evo
that's that's actually fine and I used
to teach Latin and in Latin in the the
there's a couple of different ways you
could pronounce Latin but in the
pronunciation style that I used in my
class you would pronounce an AI is e
anyway so so that's not really that
weird to me
Sebastian says check out Gatsby Jas I've
heard about Gatsby I haven't used it yet
but it sounds really cool
Jordan says there is a drupal plugin for
a rest api awesome so that's cool so if
I'll have off to remember so it
shouldn't be too big of a deal then just
to have this company install the plugin
and set up a REST API if we need it
that's awesome
Zanna says I was on fever fiber not
showed up for not fi ve or R for a while
coded small small things for for peanuts
especially CSS GS animations but I also
learned a lot from that yeah cool I was
on a similar site before too and that's
kind of how it goes you don't really
make a lot of money off the sites like
that but you do get experience so if
that's what you need then it's it's
definitely I mean it's better than doing
nothing right oh if I have says I did
pronounce the name correctly so awesome
Zanna said gave up on Fiverr because
people are mostly asked me to copy
things from other sites and didn't like
that felt like stealing yeah that kind
of stinks I mean I'm I'm all for getting
inspiration from other sites but just
straight copying I'm I don't I don't
like that yeah I mean there's definitely
a difference between you know learning
from other people but and copying from
other people
okay Evo said in regard to the to the
Drupal plug-in the drupal rest api
plugin check that out didn't really have
that much time to investigate so I mean
I'm assuming that it works in a similar
manner to the WordPress plug-in I mean
at least in terms of getting the data
you know rest the way data comes out of
REST API is somewhat similar you know
for most places okay Adam says thanks
for taking time to share this
appreciated oh I appreciate you saying
that Thanks
thanks for watching and contributing in
the chat as how did you get started
collaborating with free code camp I'd
love to do some things with them with
teaching angular so actually for free
code camp stuff ayat I started live
streaming on my own YouTube channel and
I did a few streams and then Bo from
free code camp who does all like the
JavaScript tutorial stuff he I guess
watch one of my videos so I posted in
the free code camp forum and I just I
wanted help for people to give me tips
on like how to improve my stream so I
explained what my idea was for the
stream which was just to show people
what my normal work day is like and I
asked for advice and so I think he saw
that that link in the forum watched one
of the videos and then he asked me if
I'd be interested in in doing some
streams on free code camp and so I
talked to Bo and I talked to Quincy just
through email and I ended up doing some
streams and they like the streams and so
I I said well you know I'll stream here
every day then if that's alright and
they said yeah so so I'm streaming and I
let them I let him know coincident
bow-bow that if they ever don't want me
to stream any more to please let me know
because I want to be helpful to people
and if I'm not helpful and I don't want
to waste waste of time on the chain
but evidently they must be happy with
with the streaming I think they are
Quincy occasionally will drop into the
live chat and he seems to be happy with
with what's happening and told some
people on Twitter over the weekend that
I was doing a good job so so that was
that's how it happened for me I kind of
really didn't like I didn't imagine that
that would happen at all so it was a
very very nice surprise and enabled me
to basically like instantly have an
audience of people you know because
freak I think my youtube channel has
less than 500 subscribers and free code
camps over seven hundred and seventy
thousand definitely much better
subscriber base here all right so anyway
Adam if you want to do things with free
code camp then I you know just reach out
I would say reach out to Tabo or Quincy
or both you reach out on Twitter or in
the in the forum probably Twitter would
be the most direct way to reach out and
if you have any examples of videos or
streams that you've done already then
that would be cool to just say the get
this out I'm interested and just see how
it goes from there I can't really help
you any more than that because I don't I
don't really have any decision-making
power within free code camp I just you
know I I do my my little thing you know
and and that's it I think that's kind of
how it works everybody that volunteers
with free code camp just kind of does
their own little thing to help out and
you know there are definitely some
people with Quincy and everything that
have more oversight over things but it's
very much like kind of a decentralized
thing you know there's a ton of meetups
all over the world and things and this
was very very decentralized Oh aim high
is here hey how's it going so so aim
high recently got a job so
how's it going so far I am actually I
was really excited about that because
aim high will come in from time to time
into the live chat and and give updates
from even like in the the job hunting
process and then it through the
interviews and everything and then
getting a job so I'm really excited
excited about it alright so I'm gonna
get back to coding because I just spent
a really long time in the live chat so I
see there's a couple more things that
were just posted in the live chat so
I'll get back to those in a minute
I think this is these packages have been
up on the screen long enough so I think
I'm probably safe too
I guess I'll leave them up for now so I
don't forget about configuring this
package but for now as I said the next
step is going to be making this work so
when you click one of these it actually
does filter filter this out so let's
let's just check out some of the filters
that we already have because this is not
going to be very different from what
we're already doing actually
oh did we already set this up yeah we
did I can't believe I forgot that yeah I
remember this now
yeah because someone in the live chat
had given some some code for this and
I'm sorry I can't remember who it was
I'm really sorry about that I really
usually and in somewhat decent about
remembering who contributed so really
sorry I can't remember who contributed
this little bit of code it wasn't a pull
request it was just you know copy and
pasted into the live chat but in any
case so we do have some filter by
category stuff going on and then we were
just changing the state and then that is
what we'll filter by so I don't know if
we actually put the filter on though
hold on a second let me see those
resource category
okay sorry we actually filtering
sure thing here sorry I'm just trying to
figure out what we did since I didn't
remember that we did it okay alright so
this okay alright so this category thing
in the state is what actually populates
that that select that drop-down this
category is what is gonna the filters
gonna be based on so this is gonna
change so it's going to be not the
category name but the category number so
zero is gonna give us everything so let
me go down and so when we do filter by
category if it's zero see we return true
for everything otherwise we're gonna
return so I think I have some check in
here for undefined that our return false
otherwise it's actually gonna take the
the category and return things with that
actual category so so what we need to do
now is take that select input and we
want to make it so that every time
something changes with that input
it changes States this is going to be a
cool thing to demonstrate right because
I don't think we've done this yet at
least in the stream so what we're gonna
do to this input exists in another
component so it's not gonna be as
straightforward as it normally is you
know we we can't just you know call this
function you know right here so what
we're gonna need to do is actually we're
gonna make a we're gonna make a function
that sets the state to whatever the
value is of this
and that function is going to live here
right because this state is needs to be
in this component right because this
state is gonna change things you know on
this page so first things first let's
let's make that but then we're going to
pass that that function as a prop to
here and then we can do our on change to
get the value here and on the change
what's going to happen is we're going to
call that function and we're going to
pass in the value into that function and
that's going to make it actually run the
function here change the state here and
resources and then a state change is
going to trigger a rerender and then
that's gonna be what filters everything
hopefully that made sense if it didn't
make sense when I explained it it will
probably make more sense when I actually
do it so first thing we're gonna do
let's put this we'll put it by the
filter so keep them together a bit let's
say
set cast category
that works alright so I'm gonna be set
category and we're gonna pass in
category number just can't abbreviate
that as cat num and let's basically all
we're gonna do then is go this set state
and we're gonna take category and we
want to set it equal to cat none and
that's that's it this is going to be
just really simple so now we need to go
down to here we have material select so
let's go
okay so I think that's how we need to do
this if this ends up not working I
actually just did this on a project I'm
doing for the Udacity course that I'm
taking so I can double check it on there
because I've had to do this a few times
for that project but I think that's that
should work so now this will get passed
as a prop so in here it's gonna select
input and actually I gotta remember how
to get a value from a select input
because I haven't done that in a long
time
so on my other screen I just looked up
how to get the value and the first page
I went to it's not great so let's go to
stack overflow everybody's giving jQuery
answers I don't want jQuery answers
actually
I kind of wanna see where's my select
input
okay the values are there it's correct
so
I want to select something it's that
selected
all right so just straight up value does
not work I guess I will have to look it
up I thought I might get lucky and just
try it maybe you have to see which one
is selected
can't believe I'm getting stuck on
something so simple I know I've done
this before
plenty of times maybe stuff okay well in
jQuery is dot Val which is not gonna
help me that much because I don't want
to use jQuery let me try to find it what
it is using just JavaScript
it looks like it might just be valued
hmm
let's just try it with value then
all right so on the select input we're
going to do an on change and we're gonna
say on change and
let me see actually I really I think I
do want to see how I did this on my
other project so let me bring it over
it's probably worth worth sharing so
anyway so this is my no this isn't mine
this is Bill's where's mine sorry bill
if you didn't want your project on on
YouTube I thought I had mine up
somewhere
all right so this is when and I'm pretty
sure I did it with this there we go
that's what I was I was looking for this
syntax here okay so looking for then I
could probably shorten this to E save a
bit and I don't need the first part and
when I was doing it before that was a
stateless functional component so I need
to add this props to this one breath
work and what did we call it we called
it set category all right so this cross
target value okay so let's check it out
we'll save that and then I'm also gonna
add into this function a good old
console just to see what we're getting
in case it doesn't work we'll see what
we're getting right away so let's test
it out
nothing happened all right let's see
maybe I just didn't refresh it's
possible with my I guess it's not hmm
I'll show one more time
okay so that's its not being triggered
so our own change event is not
triggering anything so we need actually
let me look at this project again
because I'm pretty sure I have a select
drop down in the project so it says here
I'm Bo
yeah this is a select on change okay I
see what's happening
all right let's try
chimes knocking I'm thinking
okay this I added this in for another
reason so this is irrelevant for what
we're doing now so on change this should
work let's check out how I pulled it in
though in the main the main component
here so I move book there we go so I
pulled it in here so it's being pulled
in as shelf
yeah it looks like it's work it's
working in here all right let's check
out
let's check this out again and see
what's going on okay so and maybe it's
just something silly like I misspelled
something okay so we have set category
so on change we're gonna get the value
right
let's
let's just take this out for a second
and see if we can get a console out of
this
nope not getting anything
no nothing okay I'm gonna go to the live
chat because it's possible that some of
you have already figured out what my
problem is and I've been foolishly
ignoring the left all right so I'm gonna
scroll up to about the time when I first
started having the problem I see there's
some questions in here I will I will
come back and get to the questions as
soon as we get this working
well so I'm just kind of scanning
through to see and someone says Jay says
there's a grandma in Japan as 86 years
old and learned how to develop an app
that's awesome
as Anna said she lived in Japan for two
years that's awesome I would love to
live in Japan I'm a big fan of sushi and
ramen and it would be amazing to go
there because there are so many places
to get sushi and ramen where I live you
can't buy ramen anywhere like at a
restaurant they just don't have it I
have to drive into Pittsburgh to find a
ramen place and even in Pittsburgh
there's there's not many places you can
go to get it with sushi
there are like two sushi restaurants
near where I live but they're not like
they're not really good I mean it's okay
it doesn't taste bad but it would it
would be cool I like the color Japanese
culture as well there's a lot of cool
things about it
okay so it looks like there's a lot of
awesome conversation going on the live
chat but not exactly related to my
problem so let's get back to the
research so I'm actually gonna bring
over I usually don't do research on this
screen but I'm going to now so let's say
say I want to think now if I've gotten
the value from a select input in one of
my previous projects aside from the one
I just checked I think I have but let's
see if it's all right
cool so evidently this is Wow sorry I
just saw this on the side here anybody
looking for a chub seeing yourself we're
developer 130,000 to 150,000 dollars a
year and you can work remote that sounds
like a great deal
ellaby that's like so much more than I
make right now I can't even imagine what
that would be like
okay let's see this said state yeah this
is pretty much what we're doing
we're getting the target value we have
unchanged
all right let me check the code again is
it seems like we're doing what you know
I'm doing pretty much the same thing and
another site that I worked on earlier
this week and it worked and it's also
pretty much the same thing that we just
saw in the stack overflow page there so
what is the problem
oh I want to check one thing where's my
so I want to check how I pass this
okay is this the problem in yeah I think
this is the problem
all right so there's definitely a
difference in how I pass this in so
that's that makes sense this is the only
thing I really haven't checked over yet
so let's find that material select so so
I would I did that kind of fast so I'm
not sure if anybody caught it but you'll
see it now so basically I was just
passing in you know this function like
that but that isn't how I did it in my
other project that that works so this is
what I need to do now is get what I'm
what I'm passing here is by a second
call whatever I won out what was i
calling it
and then i call this and set category
okay so this this makes more sense as to
how it was working I don't know what I
was thinking earlier so yeah so this
will then and should work maybe I'm
still a little worried though that even
our console.log didn't work but let's
take this out and that set it to what we
had it at before and make sure I save it
in both places and now let's give it a
try
okay not working let me check out I want
to check out what state is nice and not
showing me where status I guess I can
check out what the props are at least
mmm
okay I'm gonna check the live chat again
okay it looks like Oliver is put
something in here this is the category
and all of this process a category
you've copied it's from a savings
component oh good catch
good catch
I see let me see is this set category
and not this prop set category you've
copied from a stateless component ok
she's saying this
actually this should be right this
should be this props category so the
other the other component I use was a
stateless functional component so it was
just this set category but in this case
I need to have this props correct so I
don't think I read the comment out loud
so sorry
the the the comment was talking about
the difference between using this set
category versus this props set category
so on my my other example here I used I
guess I had clicked every but on my
other example I had a stateless
functional component so I just had to do
props set category right yeah
so at this point the only change that I
can think of the alien is different
that's really different between these
are the fact that there's some other
stuff going on here
it's not just a normal select input
so maybe what I need to look up is
so maybe hey all right there's a github
issue for this okay so someone else
using the T realize wants to get the
value
okay but all these these examples
using jQuery I don't want to use jQuery
also it's it's a different
alright I'll take one more and then
we'll try something try a few things yes
alright materialized CSS with react Jas
let's see what's going on here
okay so there was an answer but I'm not
sure whether or not it worked it says no
votes wasn't selected the this is pretty
much the exact situation that we have
but this is a little little odd so it's
saying to put a wrapper around it all
and then track this change event inside
component did mount
I don't know any any thoughts on this
method I'm not really sure that this is
really the best way to go I mean if it
works it works but it seems to me like
there's got to be a more straightforward
way of doing it
I'm gonna check the live chat again cuz
I think I have asked a few questions and
then never checked
looks like we now have a slack channel
that's cool so so if I have created a
slack channel its FCC pair programming
dot slack calm so that's pretty cool
we also have a channel an IRC channel on
freenode and it's hashtag FCC Jessie so
FCC J esse so we have that actually I
haven't logged into the channel for for
a little while I have to remember I kind
of forgotten to login
okay I'm Barry toe said maybe it's time
to restart the server so that's actually
a good idea it has happened in the past
that I couldn't figure out what is going
on and then I restart the server and
somehow it works this it's worth a shot
oh well not working
alright now this I'm gonna run through
every line and I'm gonna look at every
line and just just to say maybe that the
weird thing is is I'm not I didn't see
any error messages I mean any new error
messages but let me read them okay so I
usually get a lot having unique key prop
okay I probably should give the key prop
okay so this is a warning related to the
value on the select option so it's
possible that that is messing something
up these are just related to using
localhost out there so let's
let me see this resource drive I thought
I had added a key but I guess I didn't
I guess I'll have to pass in I get it
doesn't really matter there's no way
that that is messing up what I'm doing
now but I wouldn't need to put a key a
unique key on there and I'll just use
the ID the WordPress ID but for now
let's check this out again so
let me look
the I guess I could test and see if
something is messing it up because we're
changing it with jQuery so I could stop
initializing it and then let's refresh
so it's gonna be invisible for now so
I'm gonna have to change it manually so
this select is gonna set the
display:none so we'll just kind of
manually get rid of that
we'll check out okay so it's still not
happening so it's probably not due to to
what's going on since it's still not
working the other thing I can check out
is the actual data
[Music]
see the key value
let me remove this because we were
getting in a a warning related to that
and we could
so let me initialize this again
okay so didn't do anything except to
change so that choose the categories and
displayed right away hmm
look at this again
yes
Wow I'm really surprised I didn't think
it was going to be this difficult to
just get the value from this
let me check out okay so patrick has
pasted in a link to a github issue so
let's see
go check it out
I'm I'll bring it over
so
okay cool so this is the on change event
for select is not propagated yeah this
actually thanks Patrick
this seems like this could be exactly
our problem is that nothing's happening
for that on change event even when we
just wanted a simple console.log we
didn't get anything so this is probably
what's happening here is the the on
change event is not it's not find others
it's probably firing but it's just not
registering at all alright so I do want
to check out I'll change this okay let's
go down a bit then to this it's always
good when you go through an issue in
github whichever one has the most cool
emojis is probably the best answer if
you only remember one thing from today's
stream remember that just look for all
the emojis
okay well let's try it this is actually
somewhat similar to that other
stackoverflow thing that I saw it was
using component did mount so
just gonna scroll through really quick
to see if there's something with even
more emojis okay the only thing I don't
like about this still using jQuery
wait a second
okay so anyway I read this in which it
seems like this is similar to what
they're saying is basically like a
container around it should work
so I guess
I guess we could we can at least test it
out to see if it would work so the first
thing I'm going to test out basically I
know the same put it in a component did
mount and then binding this but based on
the other thing that I read I'm it's
possible that if we wrap this in a div
that we could get an event to fire based
on that that div unless I'm reading this
wrong which is possible because at this
point it's starting to get a bit
frustrating okay yeah that seems like
what it's saying
so this is just going to be really
simple for now just seeing if I can get
an event to fire
Hey
we get to fire once okay so we got one
change what we get do we get another one
let's see no we just got one but yep one
change come on
all right so that's not gonna help us
okay let me I'm gonna check the lap chat
again cuz now I'm starting to see some
other things here set the value on the
Select element T Anderson's has set the
value
and see
oh yeah Patrick says I can just replace
the jQuery with the document get element
by ID yeah that's that's true resin
wants someone to say hi hi Reza
okay and Oliver says try just simply
passing the function name this props a
category changes yeah
actually I kind of want to try this now
because I don't think we ever tried it
with just the console long and nothing
else see if we can get a get a response
okay
once again we're just getting one
shoot
looks like we've gotten one too
so again too sweet
hey Fabien sir how's it goin Fabian all
right I will have to see ya whether or
not we get it working I'll have to stop
with the coding and do some
question-and-answer here and maybe I
don't like 15 minutes so we'll try and
get this working so anyway so let me let
me just go back to the the github issue
on react and let's just try try some of
this stuff
okay uh
[Music]
I see that's a good answer just youth
use a different thing looks like the
link does not work
I was just looking I was wondering what
because obviously we're not using a
function name handle select change
okay yeah I'm doing all right baby and
I'm just stuck on something that should
be easy and in fact something that I
have working on another site that I got
working just a few days ago and for some
reason it's not working here
[Music]
all right so let's
yeah let me I want to go back to what we
had before I've changed a lot of stuff
so I'm gonna start just want to start
from the beginning of where we had it
oops I don't want to get that far back
okay alright so this is what we
initially started with okay
and see
yeah Patrick says men should the the on
change didn't even fire at all was just
calling it console logon load yeah so
that it wasn't really wasn't really
helping so it was probably we was
probably calling it twice because what's
the data came in and everything
rear-ended then it got caught again okay
so we're gonna try Patrick's advices
let's replace replace the dis props with
console.log e
and see what's going on okay we'll see I
may not since it wasn't even firing I'm
not even sure what we're gonna get let
me refresh
and let's change
no not getting anything
dang it I accidentally clicked on a link
now my my dev server is frozen
okay and I actually well I had to remove
that earlier than it came back when we
went back everything so
okay so let's check out its inspect it
all right I got it
I gotta get go out in the hallway for a
second
so just give me an update
I'm sorry many people yeah there's
definitely a chunk of it that I couldn't
eat off and everything would still look
like it's finished so if I have to write
yeah just make sure I want to make sure
you are aware of that because the 17th
possible starts and I don't know what
they're going to be doing there show and
tell but I know that they are so
whatever you don't
then you got two days when you get back
to see what you can publish so the main
thing is
it'll be I have things sorted out so
like here
it's okay I just want to remind you
like I just did the exact same thing a
few days ago okay
sorry for the interruption there but
that was the head of my department so
kind of had to take that because that
was my my boss's boss's boss so I really
couldn't leave her waiting and she was
actually asking about the site that I'm
working on right now and reminding me
that once the 20th comes I am done with
his site no matter what so to make sure
that whatever state it's in on the 20th
is is reasonable and you know it'll look
like it's a finished site which I don't
think she'd be a problem it looks like
it's a finished site right now at least
the version that's live so if I have to
leave something off I'll probably leave
off the the news section that's supposed
to function like a blog because right
now there's not really a lot of content
and so that's probably the section
that's the least amount of content so it
would I guess be okay if we left it off
so anyway I'm gonna check the live chat
quickly just to see what I missed for
the few minutes that I was gone and
okay looks like I didn't really miss
there was some conversation but not
directly related to our issue tell you
what here's what I'm gonna do it
occurred to me that this is actually
kind of like really weird so our issue
was related to this being materialized
framework right I mean that's what we
were thinking and that's what we're
looking at but when I didn't initialize
it as a materialized input we still had
an issue so if that's the case then
maybe the issue is not maybe there's a
like two issues potentially maybe
there's another issue so I'm gonna try
this again let's do this
and let me remove this class of input
field because it's possible that
materialized is picking up on that class
our options I think everything else was
fine and let's try this out now and see
if we get anything the only other thing
I could think of is potentially it's a
problem that all of these options are
being added in after the fact and we
could certainly test that out easily by
hard-coding some options and seeing if
that's if that's the case if it is the
case all these options then maybe we
have to put something to fix that in
component it update but for now let's
just try this
now it shouldn't have done that it
should have there we go
actually let me put
oops I need to so since materialized by
default puts display:none on select
inputs I'm gonna display block and then
that way I don't have to keep building
that all right so here's display let's
change it up and see alright so let me
bring this over so we have and I've so
much stuff let me do this again so we
can just get a more clean looking setup
here okay so look we've gotten something
right
which is better than what we had before
if if it comes down to it I'm fine with
just doing a bit of styling on this I'm
not I'm not tied down to using the
materialized input I've actually I've
been unable to use the material i style
input on a few other projects that I had
and I've been able to style it in such a
way that it looks decent not quite as
polished there's the materialized input
so that's that's fine then we can I can
definitely change it also
I'm wondering if
so basically what's happening is on this
select input materialised it's just
changing what you see into a list right
and then making that list behave
basically I could drop down potentially
if you wanted to keep that same style
all we would have to do is instead of
having a select input we just made a
list and just had click and it looks
like you know when you clicked on a
certain thing on the list then it it
updated I'd rather not have to go
through all that but those are two
alternatives that I'm thinking of to
just completely bypass all of this stuff
so at this point I'm I'm convinced now
upon seeing that
upon saying that this actually is
working when I have materialized
disabled then it's definitely
materialized ok see and then we got a
value so we got the value we want so
here's what I'm going to do I'm gonna
put back in here what we were originally
going to have which I guess was let's
just go back to get what we had before
okay so that's what we have before and
then I'm just gonna add this one again
I'm gonna take this out and leave that
off just for now I'll probably just
completely remove everything but when we
do this hopefully we'll get we can get
the filtering working and check oh what
just happened
they are reps oops
wait a second so I
oops left off a bracket there we go okay
so let's try it now
come on she's too
oh yes it's actually not shoot
it's still--it's console logging and we
got rid of our console log right we
still eat that one in here
you know what we might not actually be
using this filter off the check so this
must be the console oh that's actually
working resources yeah so it's coming
from the resource page so that's the
console log it's working it should be
setting the state correctly let's go
down to where our filters are
okay yeah maybe we don't have a filter
for that so
let's do that
I don't want to filter
so I'm gonna filter and actually what it
sorry I forgot what I called that
actually I had the price that where did
I put the price filter in sorry
gonna figure this out
what the heck
so my price filter is not working either
I had the price filter working before -
what did I do
that's really odd okay
[Music]
filter by category I need to put in I
think that's how I do it
I had all my my windows hurt out of the
order I want them to be in there we go
just don't know what I called it I hope
bunny did it it needs to be this sorry
about that
this dots
all right
it did something not exactly I wanted it
something happen
oh that not exactly what we wanted but
it's better than nothing
okay I think I'm just gonna have to stop
for now and figure this out tomorrow
because I do have an appointment at 5:00
that I'll have to leave for soon and I
want to get to your questions so just to
try to wrap up somewhat as much as I can
here the plan is basically to not use
the material as input and instead just
to style the input a bit so that it
looks it looks good
as good as you can or potentially make
some type of custom drop-down thing and
then it would it would look similar to
this input but would in fact be a list
also figure out what's going on with
this filtering it's obviously it's doing
something but not exactly what we wanted
to do so I'll just have to go through
and try some things out I'm gonna think
what else
that's about it I mean probably if I can
get that done
the search works these work so basically
just getting these two done it'll be
functional completely functional in
terms of what we want it to do could
probably use a bit of polishing up the
UI but it'll do what we want it to do so
this is really close to being
functionally ready so I'll need to check
I also want to check to make sure that
the posts actually are linked up with
the categories I expect that they are
but I just want to double check it's not
that because if it's the case that we
have categories but they're not linked
to posts then that would explain why
we're getting nothing here it wouldn't
explain why they're not showing back up
when I click all but anyway so that's
the plan
so I'll fairly work on that tomorrow or
maybe tonight I'm kind of thinking I'm
gonna have to put in some work on this
at night to get it to where it needs to
be anyway so let me go back I'm gonna go
back to the lodge that I know there's a
ton of stuff in here so I'm gonna try to
get through as much as I can before I
have to leave
so if you do have a question you could
put it in there now I'll try to get to
it if I happen to not get to it you can
message me on Twitter the links in the
description or you can put it in the
comments for this video or you could
just wait til tomorrow and ask me then
okay I'm scrolling through these I'm
going pretty quick so I can get to the
question so it's possible I might miss a
question so I'm sorry if I miss miss any
questions
okay suit sumit had a question about a
contact list in an app the web app that
they're building so I'm not sure it
wasn't us assume it if you're still here
you're still listening
I need a bit more info if you want to
send me a link if you have liked your
project on github or something then I
could check it out but I'm not sure I
could give you a good answer you know
just from you know the info that that
could be put in and the live chat it
pretty better if I could see the code so
you can message me direct message me on
Twitter and I'll get I'll check it out
okay cool Gino says I've signed up today
I assume sign up for a free code camp
and in two hours I finished the HTML and
CSS tomorrow bootstrap King that's
awesome
that's really cool
all right so aim high yeah sorry I asked
you a question about your job and then I
I got sidetracked with with the the
coding and so I didn't read your answers
I'm sorry about that but here's the
answer so aim high got a job recently
and we're all really excited so it says
first week has been brilliant working on
a project with 30 million users every
month team of four developers that's
awesome that's that's really really cool
yeah congratulations on that name House
is loving it so really happy for you
that sounds great thirty million users a
month that's a lot that's that's amazing
Janus is FF developer IDI edited on good
for coding I'm not I'm not really sure
what that is so I'm sorry I'm saying if
you're still around you could explain a
bit more I'm just not understanding the
question do you know ask what do I need
to learn to be a front-end web dev if
you're already going through the free
code camp stuff if you just keep going
through the free code camp front-end
thing that'll teach you a lot I
definitely work on some projects you
know as you pick up skills because
you'll need you know you'll need to know
how to do your own projects and setup
things like that so I would for now at
least be starting out you know free code
camp will be a great start for you and
that's aim high gave similar advice also
a nice says go on to dribble and try to
convert complex designs into code using
HTML CSS that's really good advice I
like that
Oh John John said Google developer tools
has a way to see all unused CSS rules in
each page makes it quick to find this
content cool yeah I actually I used that
when it was on Chrome Canary and it was
really cool at that point I don't think
it was ready but now it's it's in chrome
like the the normal version of Chrome so
I have to use it
haven't used in a while but that's a
that's a great idea
Eva said just heads up that chrome tool
is did cause cause some trouble before
searching for it
all right so I'm gonna skip I gotta go
in just a few minutes so I'm gonna
unfortunately I'm gonna have to skip a
lot of just like the comments in the
live chat but I will be able to
hopefully answer any questions
okay Sebastian has a question about an
app that he's building about updating
state so Sebastian if you want to send
me a link if you have it on github and
can share I'd be happy to check it out
Gino asks what types of code I need to
learn to be front-end web dev got some
answers in live chat which are good but
just for everyone else that's watching
that maybe you can't see the live chat
if you're watching later on HTML CSS
JavaScript if you only learn those you
can build web apps front-end and
back-end if you want to branch out and
you know what you want the specifically
like you could pick up PHP if you know
if that's where you want to go into
WordPress is built with PHP Drupal
Joomla so it kind of depends on where
you want to go but if you're not sure
what exactly you want to do yet within
front-end web development and I should
say if you want to just just stick the
front-end you really don't need a
back-end language like PHP but HTML CSS
javascript is you you'll be solid if you
really focus on that
okay
we had some discussions about languages
and different things to learn
Sebastian said he had to go like an hour
ago so he didn't hear any of my
responses so maybe he'll be able to
catch the the recording if I have asked
this free code camp have back-end dev
streams actually right now I think I'm
the only live coding stream on free code
camp but we might get some some new
people we're talking on Twitter so I can
set up Twitter with a few other people
who are interested and maybe like being
on this stream and like adding some
commentary and talking and then Quincy
joined in and offered to say you know
they could they could come on and
actually do their own stream if they
wanted to so that's possible I don't
know nothing's been said officially yet
but it's possible that could be coming
mrs. hoese Anna's comment sushi is
nowhere quite like in Japan yeah that's
what I've heard
I'd really love like a while back I was
talking about sushi so it's in it was in
response to that now I really want some
sushi you know I'm thinking about it
all right almost to the bottom of the
live chat it's not not a really a whole
lot of questions today a lot of activity
in the chat which is awesome
oh yes the question says almost everyone
can learn front-end development for free
what do you think will web developing
sphere become overcrowded Zanna says no
there'll be more jobs than coders that's
yeah there's definitely way more jobs
than coders right now and it doesn't
look like that's gonna change anytime
soon so I wouldn't worry about that
because you can learn to code for free
but that it doesn't guarantee that
there's quality coders you know you know
people who are really dedicated and and
you know work hard at it will be the
good ones and get the jobs and the so I
think in terms of to me I think it's
more important to think of like people
who are quality coders who really can do
the jobs not just necessarily people who
say hey it's free to learn how to code I
can learn be you know because as long as
as long as there's a shortage of quality
coders who really know what they're
doing they'll always be jobs out there
because you know just because you can go
out for free and learn what to do you
won't necessarily get a job unless you
actually are decent so in that sense you
know I don't think the markets gonna get
flooded with with so many coders just
because it's free to learn and Jeremy
says in LA I mean Los Angeles there's
plenty of companies looking for
front-end as cool
all cool and rejoining hander
Oh Andrew be balanced is working great
thanks so much
I am I talked about it at the beginning
of the show like super helpful it was
really impressed with that cool Andrew
says but too big react Redux courses
from udemy for twenty dollars so that's
a great day that's cool
keep keep us updated on how the courses
are and if they're good then you know
let us know this might be a good good
investment for learning reacts okay cool
so I've gotten to the end of the live
chat and unfortunately I have to go but
I hate to leave this unfinished and I
know I did skip over a lot of good
conversation in the chat but I'll be
back tomorrow and hopefully this problem
will be solved by the time I stream
tomorrow and I'll I'll let you know how
it went and how I ended up solving it
and so I guess you have probably same
time tomorrow I don't think I have any
meetings or anything thanks so much for
all your help in the chat today and for
for helping so many people who you know
came in newer people who had questions
they're just so much good advice and I
really really appreciate that also
thanks for creating the slack Channel so
that's cool yeah if somebody yeah off to
remember to put a check out the slack
Channel and put a link in it's FCC pair
programming slack com
so if if you're interested check that
out but I'm gonna I gotta go now
I got a hurry up and go to my
appointment and thunderstorm outside so
uh I should probably leave a bit early
and anyway I'll see everyone tomorrow
and have a great day